main review main review did someone say
you mean with you smash like if you're
excited for me review it's a very
special two-night boys we have the
legendary guest blue shirt kid hosting
meme review this time that's right
everyone we booked him it wasn't easy
but we managed to don't just cut to the
end and watch blue shirt kid okay we
have a lot of important memes to go
through today and that's what we're
gonna freakin do now a lot last week I
got a lot of flack Felix you didn't
review theaters please miss please
I liked famous live for another week
just so I have more content for this one
okay you're welcome an old boy oh boy
are there a lot of famous means it's
like the internet decided that this is
the funniest thing that has ever
happened this collective fan theory that
is just so good that everyone is behind
it I'm talking of course about the
theory that in the New Avengers movie
ant-man is gonna be in it so how are
they gonna kill thanos you might ask
well ant-man is gonna dive deep in into
Thinnes asked now if this doesn't happen
I'm gonna be thoroughly disappointed
now the memes of this it's isn't
abundance they're so goddamn many memes
about this Thanos butthole exists
ant-man nice flicka's n-word bring a new
meaning to the purple carpet of this
meme very nice Thanos use it Infinity
stones to shrink inside Edmunds ass
ant-man yeah has anyone ever considered
what ant-man might think about this put
it this way if the whole universe was at
questions the existence of the universe
was up to you would you crawl inside
another man's hands leave your top
comment down below and I will pick the
winner will win 5x Fox's Thanos when ant
met that's a lie by the way they're nice
we can ant-man dives inside as a past
can you imagine being famous always
having to have this concern at all times
he gets a weird little itch in his ass
coat oh god it's happening you should
have gone for the head I got a better
idea
brofist the Russell brothers I guess are
they the ones making the movie just to
be clear Ant Man will not be crawling
into Thanos ass and then expand in
Avengers endgame everyone this like that
everyone tweet Russell Brothers right
freaking now tell them to change their
mind if we create a petition we can get
enough people behind it using flex
sealed - shut your buck told that's true
we have not considered this in the fan
theory that does flex seal exists in
this universe because then it renders
this theory completely irrelevant I'm
sorry Matt Pat I'm doing your job here
and I don't mean to step on any toes but
have we considered flex seal this flex
seal exists in the Marvel Universe
that's all I need to know creating a
portal in your ass that leads to ant
man's ass creating a portal in your ass
that leads to ant man's own ass oh god
we haven't thought about this wait Ken
can you create portals Kenny obviously
do that so if you create a portal in
your ranks ant-man goes in the ass and
then the portal goes to head man's ass
is he still in Thanos ants whose ass is
he in if he's here inside his own man
what if Santa's is prepared
what if Stannis is dummy thick and his
ass cheeks are clapping we have also not
considered this there are many aspects
of this idea that needs to be thought
about when you feel something crawl up
your leg and then you go to your
practice you know we're all gonna die
some way we might as well have someone
crawl up your ass and explain themselves
Thanos right before ant-man grows in his
anus my time has come
god he even has to face isn't he like
something when his eyes antennas is
thick we have not considered this either
egman no don't do it
God sweet victory Royale we have leaked
footage sorry guy said in I didn't
realize it was spoilers ant-man when
Thanos is wearing a butt plug tank me
I can't do it man God is a so lame
defeating Pharaoh's by using Doctor
Strange plan okay
defeating tanners by making ant-man
explain while it's answered we know
about this theory it's very relevant and
very accurate but how about this
defeating fairness by making black widow
accused Stanners of sexual assault even
more effective than closing in on
someone else now the final theory to
rule them all is of course defeating
Thanos by revealing that his mother
Karen Thanos of Karen Thanos of course
everyone knows her did not vaccinate him
and Ironman will sneeze on him so you
know the Avengers searching for the Ant
Man after the battle hello are you still
there
Stanley seeing all the means about
Edmund killing Thanos by going up his
ass don't make me come down there you
punk Dennis when he feels ant-man
expanding and shrinking you know gotta
give him a little taste of his own
medicine
he didn't he can't just let him get away
with it he killed half the freakin
universe is that it excuse me is that it
is that enough famous memes we will of
course continue these meme and see how
it develops again we are not making any
assumptions this is just a theory this
mean gets a we're gonna have to wait
until we make an assessment we cannot
make any assumptions but it's up
I'll give it an eight mimin views that's
right we interrupt this segment for meme
reviews.reviews meme news the Shiba from
the good old Dodge meme is old the same
photo has been posted and look at that
cute little dog
it's so old this is so sad
why can't dogs live forever but some
good news to move on is that JK Rowling
has revealed that she told her parents
that they are both gay
good job JK Rowling everyone here will
meet me and myself I mean revealing we
support you making this brave decision
14 year old white girls if there's one
thing that they all share in common
besides being 14 and girls and white is
that they love sappy like ask no
question and you'll get no lies I just
blew the mind of every fourteen-year-old
girl watching this video except there
are none luckily we got none of this on
my channel pathetic disgusting instapage
if you change we in wellness to an eye
it becomes illness this is so sad this
is so incredibly sad I am crying how
could this be
wellness would never do this cigarettes
are food for broken Souls the
fourteen-year-old girl inside of me is
crying I'm okay I am NOT okay
40 year white girls it's tough being 14
year old white girl
it is tough I get it but I have the
solution for you 14 year old girl for
girls
fry and boy friend and girls and best
friend Ricardo everyone only Ricardo has
no way how is the record of still alive
I thought I killed that guy
well done Ricardo you did it buy
yourself a lottery ticket god dammit
she's broken because she believed
he's okay because he lied oh my freaking
God this has to say something about our
society forever over oh my god
128 rooted 8 980 I love you Wow
this says everything about math I think
random ha ha ha
a boy gave a girl 13 roses 12 the real
one was fake then their boy said to the
girl I will love you till the last rose
dies oh the last one will die because
it's fake that is deep because that
means people love her forever
but of course remove the F and forever
and you get [ __ ] she believed he lied
everyone else can appreciate Sabine
Sabine hello my name is Sabine Sabine is
the answer to this problem
Sibbi what a guy I love Sabine have I
told you boys to be regular man will lie
to you
not at all believable is impermanent
amber moto sob Vick will never tell you
a lie very believable it's everlasting
it's literally mortal Sabine so even if
you're watching this video I would love
to get you the hostname review I think
that would be really cool and make all
these fourteen-year-old girls stop
crying next Steve gets on it eternally
mortos status mean next meme ten year
old me when I finally get to push the
shopping cart I am speed ha it's another
cartoon text underneath that becomes
different things when you like and our
dumbass believes you I am sube sube he
makes a comeback when people have
stopped posting car means but you refuse
to let it go I decide when I'm done u.s.
deployed troops to Vietnam North Vietnam
I am Tory when your mom asked you the I
don't this is so stupid but it make me
laugh when your mom asked me why you
were
in the bathroom for 46 minutes i paid me
god damn it is so dumb well Oh God when
you have exams next week but your last
five brain cells wants to make the most
ambitious cross over me I am speed Jesus
King Christ
well done when you have three hour exam
and you return your papers in five
minutes because you only knew your name
I am still God man when you make it the
Yola version of the I am speeding before
it dies speed I am I mean that makes
sense
life hack avoid red lights by driving at
114 million 4824 miles per hour this
velocity will blue shift them enough to
appear green I am this blue is that a
good meme I don't think so I tried now I
believe it's time for the greatest host
of all time blue shirt kid to make his
appearance
everyone smashed like for blue shirt kid
and I will see you guys with this
independent theater sir we're meant to
be expendable not to me atleast when
YouTube is like supporting cooperations
more now so if we need to support
independent creators at least that's
what I think playing multiplayer games
be like Indian I hear it his brain yeah
it does happen a lot actually like I
play a lot of 419 BS yeah I play pop
Jeon so a lot of small kids just blow my
ear off no one swallowing my kids
not subscribe to beautify because he
said p-series Bassanio nine you know not
me with angry faces it doesn't matter
who who is number one high and subscribe
to him for the means now you know me
with happy faces with the happy faces
one guy group you're okay why do people
started hating YouTube nowadays they're
dumb it doesn't matter
first of all because of the new Dubai I
get kicked out of a window
carefully isn't you know pewdiepie
subreddit cropping me the thing but that
did happen like it was just like yet I
suffered it was filled with my means for
like a good two days which is nice thank
you for your attention
it means a lot other people who said
nice things the blue shorty
well it is true like a lot of other
people said a lot of nice things like me
but they didn't get all the recognition
of they like but lower less something
yeah yeah I think this is Sherlock that
a god- should not like evil I gave the
total that was not be in the right place
at the right time
okay so we reacting to a video I will
not sure which one it is like send me a
link there were a few posted minecraft
Oh
[Music]
so for it of me in winter so I used to
play a lot of Minecraft when I was
younger and this would take a lot of
effort thank you to whoever made it they
actually even make the background Wow
business here ah got a nine-year-old ah
blue shirt k blue shirt kid blue shirt
came true yes
you want pyramids we got them
oh you're into castles huh we got you
covered baby you want some bets easy we
got it all this game is still relevant
god damn it